can you just break down why the pyramids
are so amazing outside of just the
visual stimulus that we've all seen in
postcards well yeah I mean the reality
of them is probably stranger and more
interesting than anything people can
think up in terms of fiction it's just
they're they're for the longest time
have been not only like the tallest
man-made structure but they've been some
of the most precisely man-made
structures we've ever accomplished like
we didn't uh it wasn't until like the
1700s that we even developed enough
Precision to be able to Define just how
accurately those things are aligned to
things like True North we're still
discovering crazy coincidences about
them in terms of you know they're
encoding uh these fundamentals of nature
um the Great Pyramids like it's just I
can talk about it it's a scale model of
the northern hemisphere it's just like
what do you mean by that well there's
there's let's break down some of the
Precision sure so it's the the Great
Pyramid it's it's when we mostly that's
the one that's been studied we actually
haven't done a whole lot of studying on
the other pyramids it's something that's
severe severely lacking in fact we've
not even cleared off the basis of some
of the other pyramids up at Giza it's
crazy we still to this day haven't done
that but that pyramid itself the Great
Pyramid the one that we all know and
look at the biggest one it's aligned to
True North within just you know a
fraction of a of a degree off I mean
there's we just don't build with that
type of precision even today the in fact
the only building we made that was that
precise was like an observatory in
France that was the first one we ever
made that even came close to that degree
of precision they made that in the 1800s
that's just one aspect of it though it's
yeah it's insane apart from it being
just the tallest building for Forever
Until the Eiffel Tower was built so so
the traditional historical narrative is
that these were built what 4 500 years
ago something like that somewhere around
the 2500 BC
so they build this in 2500 BC and then
it takes us until 1800 yeah A.D in order
to build something taller taller yeah
just taller not even as precise yeah not
nowhere nearest person years later 4 500
years later whatever it is so you can
understand why people start to question
the historical narrative well it falls
apart under any rudimentary examination
just the logistics of trying to build
that thing alone so you have to the way
that they there's very little evidence
that actually ties it to the guy they
say who built it's a guy named Khufu is
like a pharaoh of the fourth Dynasty Old
Kingdom and he they have to try and tie
it to well because the whole story is
like it's a tomb for him so you know
when he came to power he probably said
we're going to build this thing as my
term so they had to get it done inside
his Reign right so that sort of pins it
to like well 20 to 25 years okay so you
can break it down from there and say
Well it weighs like five million tons
and no kidding and it's it's like two
and it's made up of a round two
somewhere between two and two and a half
million blocks of stone weighing you
know any of it like two three tons some
of them some of the big granite blocks
on the inside where like 70 80 tons it's
insane and these blocks are coming from
quarries that are some of them yeah the
granite came from quarries that are like
a thousand kilometers away to the South
they had to be shipped up a lot of the
limestones it's made up of granite in
the inside the outside is uh two types
of limestone the core masonry is
this limestone a lot of it did come from
Giza not all of it there's actually
nowhere near enough quarrying to make up
for all of it the Cairo area and then
the outside casing stone is something
called Tura Limestone it's very fine
white uh version of limestone that came
from a fair distance away but you can
break it down from there so if you go
well it's 25 years two and a half
million blocks of stone it basically
means you for 25 years you have to be
putting one block of stone in place
finished shipped carved quarried put in
place every five minutes every day for
25 years 24 7. non-stop 24 7 Non-Stop
and now that we're Union hours no Union
hours yeah no no breaks no whatever it
is I mean it's crazy and that that is
only the pyramid and you've got to
remember also pyramids are part of a
complex there's there's two other
pyramids there and then there's like
three little there's a bunch yeah that's
like nine or ten there yeah originally
but there's just that one pyramid it's
not just when you build these pyramids
that they're part of a complex not the
other pyramids but they have a Causeway
they have these they call Everything's a
temple or ceremonial but there's there's
temples there's years of work just in
preparing the ground the whole
Foundation of what's around the pyramid
I love going to Egypt and showing people
Everyone stands there and look up at the
pyramids I'm like look down at your
[__] feet look at what you're
standing on you there's these massive
floor tiles that have been put into the
ground some of these things weigh up to
like 200 tons and they're fit together
like a geometric puzzle and done so
precisely you can't stick a razor blade
in between the gas I didn't know that oh
it matches it's picked up on that at all
so you're saying that they dug down and
then created a flat surface a foundation
and then tiled the foundation yeah with
these but but some of these I mean
you're talking tall this thick some of
them even bigger in fact the middle
pyramid is even more impressive in that
regard because it's built into a side of
a hill like it's literally a sloping
Hill so they dug down on this side and
they've raised it up on this side they
made this flat platform for it and it's
it's just astonishing engineering so
you've got to factor in and of course
these types of projects you don't just
make it up as you go along right so how
long does it take to design it plan it
yeah put the plant is that's years doing
the foundation work that's probably you
have to make sure there's enough Stone
to even achieve it just Logistics is
this massive problem I actually would
love to do the exercise
of working backwards because we've done
some experiments on things like okay
using really primitive methods which is
what you know the mainstream guys say
they used it takes this long to cut
stone we've done a few little
experiments here and there but you can
use that and work backwards try to
estimate how many cuts of stone do we
need how long would that have taken yeah
how long is it going to take to ship
this [__] that's right you can see based
on what is it ax and chisel or whatever
it is yeah chisels so well this is the
hammer and chisel the stupidest thing
about it it all is is wonders of ancient
Egypt the pyramids these giant Granite
single piece statues and and columns and
they tell you that it was all made with
round balls of stone and Flint chisels
just like repeatedly bashing on on them
so let's assume grinding on them with
sand but let's assume it was you could
calculate no no but even if we were to
like let's calculate how long it would
take to take that round Stone and the
Chisel yeah and chip away and create
these perfectly I I don't I don't even
symmetrical but like these perfectly
shaped you know uh you wouldn't even be
able to get them perfectly symmetrical
but even even
how long it would take yeah and have you
tried to do that math no but it's on my
list of things to do in particular I'm
interested in like the granite as well
because it Grant is so hard it's so hard
there's a few things involved in the
granite it's it's you know they they say
well they they grinded on it with sand
and like they get a copper bar and we've
done these experiments it takes it's
much harder like that's the other thing
that people try to compare like the work
of the Romans and a lot of times the
Greeks they all work in Marble like this
is a very very soft Stone relative to
Granite like frankly granite's a stupid
material to try and do this stuff it's
so it's harder than steel it's yeah it's
like a 6.57 on the most scale you know
diamonds that are 10 your fingernails
that are two coppers at three bronzes of
four steals like a five and a you know
six what is it normal out of curiosity
marbles like I think it's like a
three-ish so this is theoretically twice
as hard yeah it's just a super soft I
mean you had mentioned uh like like
molecular manipulation
yeah so that's the speculation realm but
it does it does to me and and this you
can see a bit more of that I think you
go like South America because they a lot
of the real megalithic stuff in places
like Peru and just so we can define
megalithic a megalith is just a giant
Stone Giant stonewalls yeah I call stuff
that's megalithic is I would Define it
as like yeah walls and structures made
up of massive single pieces of stone
yeah typically showing signs of
precision and how they're built and just
perfect alignment like making these sort
of modelist walls is not easy like we
don't do that today like this is what
you know more I think this is one of the
cool things that you've exposed in a lot
of your contemporaries have exposed is
that ancient history isn't studied by
um what it is Architects
right like so so they're applying these
ideas and principles to the information
that they have but they don't know what
the [__] Mo scale is so they're
finding some tools and they're seeing
some locks and they're going okay this
is how they probably chopped up
nearing is Limitless yeah you can do
whatever you would be like no you can't
well an engineer shows up yeah and then
it looks at the granite and goes wait
they did what with the granite yeah yeah
it's the engineers that come along and
in a lot of cases this the whole like
all the problems that come up with that
Orthodox story when it comes to
engineering topics that's been raised by
Engineers it's it's it's a strange thing
to me it's like you wouldn't ask an
archaeologist to to design the chair
that he's sitting on right yeah yeah but
if it's an ancient chair he's going to
claim domain over it and dominion over
it and say I'm the expert I don't care
what you say yeah so a lot of that
happens and that's not to say they
haven't tried to make studies into it
and I've that's part of my work I dive
into these studies and kind of tear them
apart for because they're ultimately
really silly and when you go to Egypt
you take Engineers construction experts
Architects people look at it and they
just see it immediately go this is
nonsense yeah are you not this isn't the
work of a primitive civilization or a
Bronze Age civilization with simple
tools and then yeah you come come back
to the pyramid and when you start to
realize like there's so much more
involved in this that there's evidence
of this of the people that build it
having you know Cosmic knowledge having
a knowledge of the planet the
dimensionality of the earth to a crazy
degree like so if you take the his easy
statistic if you take the height of the
Great Pyramid you multiply it by 43 200
you get the polar radius of the Earth so
what does that mean polarity so from the
center of the earth to the North Pole
radius if you take the perimeter length
of the Great Pyramid you measure around
the perimeter of it and you multiply
that by 43 200 you get the equatorial
circumference of the earth so the length
of the the uh of the of the uh right of
of you know the the Equator so it's 43
000 so 40 this is this gets into Randall
Carlson territories it's a it's a four
three two seven two you know seven it's
it all relates back to um
uh I guess the cosmic sort of cycles and
all of these processional numerology
when you talk about you know procession
of the equinoxes you're familiar with
this term so it's the great year you
know right now we're in the age of
Pisces it's that 26 000 year cycle
that's defined by where the sun rises on
the on the uh on the solstice and it's
like under what constellation does it
rise so right now we're in the age of
Pisces uh where we're transitioning into
there's a whole song about this you know
what the next stage is
Aquarius right and in fact there's
references in the Bible there about this
it literally this and think about like
Jesus kind of represents the age of
Pisces in a lot of ways
yeah they have the Jesus fish on the car
it's always a giggle because it's like
okay it's Jesus but you're actually you
it's an analogy for the age of Pisces
that we live in and you know he was um
you know he was a he's part of his
disciples were a fisherman he fed people
with bread and fish uh the age before
Jesus 2 000 years ago was the age of
Aries the ram so think about another
biblical figure that existed Isaac in
the old time well yeah Moses as well
right and he blew he blew the Rams Horn
you know um and before that I wonder if
that was him trying to talk because he
had a speech impediment I wonder if like
they thought it was a ramswarm but he
was just like
maybe it just sounds like a ramsorm yeah
yeah it could have been yeah that's okay
yeah yeah well and it goes further too
it's like you go back further and the
age before that another 2000 years
before that was age of taurus the ball
so the sun's Rising under the
constellation of Taurus on that spring
solstice
and the story about Moses do you
remember what happened when he came down
from Mount Sinai with the Commandments
from God when he was you know what he
found his followers doing worshiping
ball yeah worshiping the golden calf and
he murdered all that [__] and
they smashed the idol up it's sort of
representation of age of Taurus's ending
now we're in the age of Aries now we're
in the age of Pisces and then there's a
part in the Bible I can't just going
from memory uh it's they're talking
about Passover or the last supper and
one of Jesus's disciples asked him you
know what will we do without You O Lord
like what happens when you're gone he
says you know have no fear go into town
find the man bearing a pitcher of water
follow him to his house and there you
will find sustenance so you know how is
Aquarius described or shown it's like a
man bearing a picture of water right so
they're literally telling so this is
it's this Cosmic knowledge that's
encoded in these stories okay and it's
encoded in in monuments like the parent
like the pyramid it's it's not you know
it it they it they even have knowledge
of the pyramid it encodes the the
specific shape of the Earth
by that I mean the Earth being this
oblate spheroid right we're a little bit
fatter around the edge than we are
around North South right because we spin
yeah so we're not a perfect sphere that
ratio you'd call it the ratio of
latitude to longitude so if you take
that grid of latitude and longitude you
spread it out on the planet yeah you go
down to one quarter of one degree and
you measure it so it's a little bit
further sort of East-West than it is
north south that ratio of latitude to
longitude is expressed in the pyramid
because there's it sits on something and
talk about the foundation it sits on
something just sits on the foundation
called the sockle so it's like they call
it a qubit height it's about this High
sticks out about this far so it gives
you two ways to measure the perimeter
length right you can measure the base of
the pyramid or you can measure the base
of the soccer the soccer being slightly
larger and when you Ratio or you can
pitch you compare those two numbers it's
the launches latitude and longitude and
bear in mind that we couldn't figure out
how to measure longitude accurately in
our own civilization until the turn of
the what the the the 19th century I
think that's what it was James Cook's
the second voyage of Discovery we could
not measure longitude to save ourselves
until we developed chronometers and
watches accurate enough to do so and
you're saying uh according to the
traditional archaeologists 4 500 years
ago and you believe probably much longer
yeah they knew yeah so if we're
accepting things
yeah if we're accepting traditional
archeology there's just all these crazy
coincidences and none of that they had
no idea that if he multiplied so long as
you longitude and latitude by the time
they just were not aware they were not
privy to this they had no proof to show
that they were they say it's a
coincidence all of these things you keep
coming up with them because there's
other you know there's some people make
an argument that the speed of light is
encoded in the damn thing you know
there's all these crazy golden ratios
and metrics when you get into like the
king's chamber and the geometry of that
uh it relates back to the meter there's
so many interesting studies about it but
it's generally all described and hand
waved away as well it's just
you're approaching This and like a lot
of people in your position are going
these are a lot of coincidences and it
might be easier to look at these people
who built the pyramids as a different
group of people than the dynastic
Egyptians that live you know 4 500 years
ago exactly what I think I I think what
we're looking at and this it goes so
much further than the pyramids to me it
is we're looking at the remnants of A
Lost Civilization and that was that that
left stuff they might have left cultural
knowledge they might have left
architecture and objects that were
inherited by essentially a Mesolithic
people that developed into a Bronze Age
culture that we call the dynastic
Egyptians I think we have a good
understanding of the dynastic Egyptian
civilization I the tools that we've
found you know the way they live their
life that's the job of the egyptologist
and I think we're right about those guys
I just don't think you can say they made
everything and in fact they themselves
don't say that like their own history
goes back 40 something thousand years so
when do you think they're met oh I think
so there's an it's a lot of I think
pre-catical a lot of this stuff and then
I'm not saying the pyramids as they are
you do have to kind of look through all
this stuff with the lens of I need a
preface this because it's like there
were thousands and thousands of years of
renovation reuse rebuilding adaptation
and then thousands of years of
deconstruction quarrying like they've
literally been ripping Stone off these
pyramids for the last couple thousand
years and selling it yeah up until about
50 60 years ago oh wow so it's just that
you know you have to look at it through
that lens and the Egyptians spent many
thousands of years working on this stuff
and renovating it using it for their own
purposes but I think a lot of this stuff
goes back to before the cataclysm like
the younger dries period which we can we
can talk more about but potentially goes
back way further than that if I'm going
to speculate I mean hundreds of
thousands of years potentially 50
because even and this is where it gets
interesting because there's so many
other vectors from modern science right
now that are that it should be affecting
that story of History right the last 20
years we've seen incredible advances in
our knowledge base not just the
cataclysm stuff to me that's the key
that kind of unlocks the whole picture
but even the history of the human race
itself right we thought for the longest
time if you're creationist six thousand
years okay but for the longest time
Victorian era like well maybe it's 50
000 years as a species then once we
start dating human remains we get to
like 190 000 years ago like we found
some stuff in Ethiopia and then recently
in the last something like 300 right
Morocco they found a modern anatomically
correct yep moroccis you uh you nailed
it and that's that takes about 300 000
years old that's still the oldest actual
thing in the fossil record but now we've
got DNA studies uh there's a study
that's done recently that shows like we
diverged Us in the end of those like
diverged from a common ancestor
somewhere in the 800 000 year old range
is what they're guessing and then the
latest thing in the last couple years
studies into teeth morphology like the
really nerdy studies into how teeth
evolve and grow over time and they're
putting it back at 900 to a million
years old okay as a species so so there
is a chance that human beings have been
here for a million years
in our current form yeah anatomically
correct yep humans you could shave one
down and put him out in the street it's
like it looks like a Fraser and you
haven't seen him yeah now
yeah that's crazy now we see how much
changes within a thousand years we see
how much change within 200 years yeah
right like from the 1800s to now a lot
[__] changes so it is very possible
there could be a civilization
civilization that pops up achieves uh
immense success it gets wiped out
happens again like almost on some Matrix
[__] yeah it's it's a cycle I actually
do think that's it's a long convoluted
thing to get to about why this stuff's
important is I do think there's a cycle
almost of civilization and catastrophe
or cataclysm and we've been through it